in November of 2018 and Germany's
largest electronic retailer any diesel
to CPUs for every CP that in tow sold
may be sold over 16,000 rising CPUs
while Intel was even struggling to get
to 8,000 the top four CPUs by sales were
the 2600 then 2700 X 2600 X and finally
that 87 or ek and as you can see three
out of the four top side CPUs were
riding Steve use anybody's second
generation rising CPUs accounted for 47
percent of the sales while Intel's
caught philic only counter for twenty
two percent clearly anyways performing
much better than in tone in terms of
sales and they seem to be a consumer
favorite but just two years ago nobody
would even consider AMD when shopping
for a CPU so what happened in such a
quick period of time and within beer
stock price folding in half in just the
last couple of months are the next
[Music]
welcome to hari sabe
first of all while we like to credit aim
these super high value rising CPUs for
making a huge dent in the market we
cannot forget that into's lack of
innovation and ignorance was a big if
not bigger factor that lets us change
aim these violent abuse haven't even
been out for two years while in toast
ignorance has persisted for several
years and it is actually this ignorant
opened up the pathway for AMD success as
a result we have to take an in-depth
look at Intel's lack of innovation in
order to fully understand why Rison was
so successful Intel announced a 40
nanometer architecture way back in
August of 2014 and promised the 1080
architecture would come out in just a
couple of years however we are currently
in January of 2019 and even the latest
launch from Intel just a couple of
months ago was still on the 40 nanometer
architecture now that's not even that
big of a deal because architecture
doesn't lead to that big of a
performance upgrade in the first place
the main place that Intel lost was their
lack of upgrade
every single year in September of 2011
intohe launched the 2700 K which was a
four quart eight thread CPU with a base
clock of 3.5 meters and a max turbo
frequency of 3.9 G Hertz in 2017 Intel
launched a 77 RK which is also a fork or
a thread CPU with a base clock of 4.2
good Hertz and a max turbo frequency of
four point five gigahertz that means
that in those five and a half years in
to increased her max turbo frequency by
0.6 givers and that was the only main
difference
that's almost less than 0.1 K hurts
increase every single year even here it
wasn't too bad because all cores eight
twins is more than enough for most
mainstream users it is okay to launch
similar products every single year as
long as there is more incentives for
example they could reduce the price
every single year and make it more
accessible to more people or at least
include a better stock cooler with it
but no no the 7700 case still costed
$350 just like the 2700 K and there was
still no stock cooler overclockable CPUs
and the CPS that did have them still had
that crap on for 90s or something this
trend continued into the high level
Bravo EC series as well in toast I 760
Mary Kay had 8 cores and 16 threads and
inta was the many $1100 for that and the
top-end
6950 X was a 10 core 20 thread CPU with
the base clock of 3 gigahertz and a max
turbo frequency of 3.5 years and wait
for it $1,700 as you guys can see by
2017 everyone was very fed up with what
Intel had to offer are hungry for
something very new and that is precisely
when write and talk really started to
spread soon enough but April of 2017
Rison had launched and embodied
everything that in tow was lacking
rising 3 you finally had 4 full
functional
replacing i3s which only had dual-core
and higher third up to four cores
rather than five mashed I sevens and
even beat them in terms of core count
with six cores and twelve threads and
being able to overclock all the way to
four gigahertz finally risin 7 matched
and beat the i-76 900k from Intel's
enthusiast line of the horizon 7 1700
had 8 cores and 16 threads and could
overclock all the way to three point
seven Gators just like the 6900 Kaede
and the horizon 717 herd came in at $330
while the Intel i7 6700k still cost of
1089 dollars on top of this angry
promised to support aim for up to 2020
and had an aggressive game plan but the
70 meter arc to her CPUs coming just two
years later
so clearly why isn't as packed the value
not to mention it's amazing stock
coolers so everyone who wanted a more
cores and more value quickly flocked
over to Rison however it wasn't all
birds and sunshine bison dead habit set
of issues a meanie hadn't been a big CPU
player in several years and most
software and games were optimized
towards Intel CPUs as a result writing
CPUs were often limited by software and
additionally baigan CPUs were also not
the best with RAM support many popular
Ram could simply could not run at full
speed
also for gamers Intel CPU is still the
clear choice because while anybody
offered a lot more value in toast EPS
were still better gaming due to high
level of singletery performance and gain
to be optimized for them so after launch
of Rison AMD enthusiasts couldn't be
more ecstatic that AMD was finally
bringing competition into the market and
couldn't be happier to buy a rotten CPU
Bryson also attracted many people from
in toeside who are really sick of in
toast lackluster upgrades and I wanted
to try something different
however for most people while Rison did
turned our heads into us to the clear
choice because writing is still so new
and didn't
to have any market proof and Amy's bad
track record did not help with that
however that was just the beginning
an empty was nowhere close to being done
just a couple of months later Amy
launched a dripper and a 1950 X has 16
cores and 32 threads and came in at
$1,000
and this is when inter Billy started
feel the pressure and this could be seen
in how the scrambles launches 18 core
CPU but they still overcharged for it at
$2,000 and later that year Intel also
launched the first mainstream six core
CPU with the 87 or decade but despite
all these efforts law people still went
over to AMD side soon enough the holiday
season 2017 rolled around and AMD
offered very aggressive deals in order
to push out their CPUs you could get the
flagship 1800 X on new egg for just over
$300 and you can see that this deal
definitely work because over 40% of the
people we saw this deal bought it right
after intel on the other hand we're
struggling to sell their CPUs because
they didn't have enough stock because
they rushed to launch at 800 K and as a
result the 80s MRK cost her over $400
and it didn't stop right there either on
new egg you can actually get a 1950 X
that's right a 16 core 32 thread CPU for
$800 at this point I was completely
unheard of aimed a completely wiped out
the holiday season and really started to
grow while in tow was still struggling
to get onto 10 nanometer architecture
soon after Andy's ape use came out as
well and this resulted issue that AMD
CPUs did not have integrated GPUs and
this distracted a super budget builders
as well and then Ryan's second
generation came out and it was more than
anybody could have ever expected now
only did AMD increased a max turbo speed
from four point organ Hertz to four
point three meters which actually isn't
that big of a deal but they slashed the
price up their flagship CPU the 800 X
from $500 through 2700 X which was $330
on top of this ami offered really nice
stock colors with all their CPUs so not
only did aim the add a good boost like
Intel this every year but they also
included a stock cooler and heavily
reduced the price and by this point
software and games are pretty well
refined to run with Rison the 87 arcade
did Billy I taught the 1200 X in terms
of gaming performance but any type of
productive tasks the 27 X easily took
the ground the only Democrat because the
80s America attracted was the really
hardcore gamers who didn't mind spending
a bit more money to get the best gaming
performance available but for everyone
else the tourism hi Rex was a clear
choice soon after Tiger / 2 came out and
this was another Marvel most people were
just expecting some more clock speed and
maybe even cheaper price like mainstream
rising however any PR something much
bigger in mind Andy did precisely that
with the 29:20 X and it's why not 50 X
but they also introduced two new SKUs
between $70 X and the 2990 WX which each
had 24 cores of 48 threads and 32 cores
and 64 threads respectively on top of
this the 2990 WX costed $1700 which was
cheaper than in cost i7 Sam 9e d XE 18
core CPU which costed $2000 this CPU was
literally three her dollars cheaper than
the 7a exe while having almost double
the cores and threads
finally the most recent event the
holiday season of 2018 with some
questionable move from Intel with the 97
recámara they removed the hyper
threading and another 40 nanometers
architecture series you should be able
to clearly see when Andy was able to
easily dominate the holiday season and
that's where we are right now so what
does the future hold for AMD well third
generation rising is
around the corner and there are a lot of
rumors floating around and very high
hopes the rumors are all over the place
and I'm not quite sure what Angie's
going to offer but I can confidently say
that whatever AMD brings it is going to
be great and Intel has to do something
very quickly or they're going to be left
in the dust
speaking of getting left in the dust
Nvidia made many questionable decisions
last year starting off with over prized
Newton series GPUs - launching a very
overpriced series with the mid-level
2060 costing three hundred and fifty
dollars nvidia clearly made some
misplaced and this is reflected in their
plummeting stock price and aimed east
na'vi may accentuate on india's misplace
weather aimed a post through the GPU
market or not ambi is definitely doing
very well in the cpu market and seem to
be continuing that rapid growth and the
main reason for this is because aim D
has the consumers best interest in mind
many big companies like Apple say they
do too but it is more than questionable
but I can confidently say that AMD truly
does have a consumers best interest in
mind because they know that the happiest
consumers are the happier they are and
hopefully it will keep that in mind as I
continue to grow to be one of the
biggest tech giant's there is so what do
you guys think about AMD do you think
all technically should be like then make
sure post that down below also I tried
something new today with all the steam
changes and background changes so if you
like that then make sure to smash that
like button and show your appreciation
and finally if you like see more videos
just like this one then make sure to hit
that subscribe button but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one
[Music]